[Musica]
all
razzi è un piacere e un onore parlarvi
parlarvi qui a te l'ex di reggio emilia
un ringraziamento speciale a sarah e
laura e mihaela e luca tutti gli altri
chi rendono possibile questo evento
davvero unico
sono the new girl oggi vorrei discutere
con te una grande correnti aidia il
titolo del mio discorso è come la
letteratura può cambiare il punto mi
vieni sempre chiesto come scrittore come
qualcuno che studia per diventare un
professore di letteratura perché leggere
a che cosa serva la letteratura perché
ne abbia bisogno per illustrare perché
leggere ea cosa serva la letteratura
vorrei raccontarvi una storia questo è
una storia vera
c'era una volta un ragazzo e una ragazza
questo ragazzo ha visto questa ragazza
ad una festa come morti story classiche
ed è amore è stato subito presso di lei
e se n'è innamorato di lei a prima vista
ma questo ragazzo ha avuto un problema
non aveva la sua il numero di telefono
aveva la sua imer non poteva cercarla su
facebook o su instagram
perché
questa storia accaduta prima di giorno
in di internet
nemmeno riusciva a cercarla su ruby code
numeri di telefono sul pubblico degli
indirizzi perché non c'erano nemmeno
cose del genere
a questo ragazzo ha avuto un otre
problema autore problema per che diverrà
in un tempo e in soffiata di matrimoni
combinati in quel tempo in corso scelta
non potevo spessori con chiunque che tu
voglia nato presti sposarvi la persona
che due genitori e che è giusto scietà
ti vogliono sposare questo ragazzo era
fidanzò con altra persona
e questa ragazza anche era fidanzata con
auto o ragazzo finito
fine della storia no non è la fine della
storia
perché nove anni dopo questo ragazzo ha
visto questa ragazza per seconda volta
passando per la strada e subito si resi
conto o chi era proprio innamorato di
lei come era prima forza ma entrambi di
loro matrimoni erano stati organizzati
in quarta in corso sciata non era un
modo di uscirne lui non potessi fare
niente consiglio
treni dopo entramble di loro sposarono
con la gente che i loro genitori avevano
certo per loro però ho 33 anni dopo
questa ragazza ora dona era morta
lui questo ragazzo ora l'uomo è stato
devastato
ora cosa ne avrebbe fatto nel suo dolore
sentore che se ne era andata trova uno
sfogo tela nella letteratura nel letture
nel libri a letto migranti story the
amore della bibbia jacob e rachel le
canzoni per canzoni ha letto le grandi
storie idee amore della mitologia greca
piramo e tisbe orfeo euridice oriani hat
seo ha detto anche le grandi storie d
amore del roero manu eni a enel eni ed
di virgilio ha anche letto tutti i
grandi scrittori e poeti del suo tempo e
lea presso sua esperienza personale del
amore insoddisfatto con quello col coro
tutti story a fusi insieme e creando in
lavoro tutto sua un nuovo epopea questo
è pop ea questo epico
questo lavoro ha cambiato la letteratura
mondiale è anche cambiato il mondo
a chi ha amato questo lavoro la divina
commedia
si no
ma questo ragazzo
naturalmente era dante alighieri questa
ragazza era la famosa di attrice
portinari e qui dietro di me era la
pittura di dante e beatrice questa
storia è accaduta è avvenuta non molto
lontano da qui in firenze nel tardo xiii
secolo ea inizio del xiv secolo la
divina commedia di dante a cambiarla
lingua ci ha dato la lingua italiana
moderna toscano di dante divina commedia
anche cambia la letteratura mondiale
creando nuova genere
il generale dell epopea religiosa e non
solo a cambio la lingua nam solo a
cambia la letteratura mondiale ma anche
cambiata il mondo ci ha dato di idea ter
amore romantico di idea che ogni persona
ha un persona speciale un vero amore
un chiamato a quasto in inglese passione
in in italiano in anima gemella
questa idea dell'amore romantico rimasto
latente per diverse s arcore fino a
quando è stata ripresa con grande
entusiasmo dal movimento romantico dal
xix secolo per gli aedi sa che tu poter
dovresti smussarli la persona speciale
per due
amore verrà tua anima gemella
hackett una bi sogno dovreste sposarli
con una persona che tu i genitori ho
chiuso sia tav ti vogliono sposare
questo è di aa di amore romantico regni
ancora oggi uno dei più importanti più
potenti idea nel mondo dando forma alla
nostre concezioni di amore e di
matrimoni di relazioni e ci ha venduto
noi non attraverso scientifica
attraverso qualche matematica ancorché
tecnologica è venuto da noi attraverso
la cultura attraverso la letteratura
oltre 700 anni passati di tacco tempo di
dante e noi soffriamo anche stesso
dolore da dante e beatrice e
condividiamo la stessa so niente all
amore ed è felicità di dante e beatrice
tante sapeva che nessuna scoperto
scientifico può guarire il cuore
spezzato e che nessuna equazione
matematica può risolvere l'enigma del
amore non corrisposto
questo tante sapeva era solo il compito
della cultura antera letteratura ed è a
loro per dante ed è ancora anche per noi
dante guardò profondamente nel mare di
letteratura del core tour del lettore i
libri e quando ritorno a guardoni nuovo
cambio la letteratura mondiale e anche
cambio il modo anche noi approfondiamo
nelle letture nelle libre chissà cosa
succederà quando guarderemo di nuovo
chissà quante morandi idea scopriremo in
quel mare ferrè ciente chissà in che
modo ognuno di noi attraverso la cultura
natura verso la letteratura cambierà il
mondo grazie grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]